ho la mia Mork ettà o Oia Perdona e che
da quando sono tornata in Italia non
riescono a parlare spagnolo
che entra proprio dentro eh Quando vai
in Spagna Ti rendi conto che la spesa
sia in Italia sono orrible Pensa che a
Madrid sono andata a ballare e c'era
tutto il Castellitto e pelo comunque che
avevo extra Esposito a chi è moimatia è
in serio non sei mai stata alle Spagna
Uff che evitia devi andare quando vai
dimmelo che ti dico tutti i migliori
posti per fare Fiesta eh basta flipar la
cosa che noti subito è la differenza nei
ragazzi cioè gli italiani sono proprio
quelli poi a sé gli spagnoli invece sono
un museo Marshall romanticoso adesso un
sacco che Tear voglio mi sono innamorata
gommosa in quinta Avete poi gli spagnoli
amano le italiane ossea totale Ti devo
raccontare e guarda un sacco di cose
perché non ci vediamo uno di questi
giorni facciamo un po' di salseo ma un
morsa a tagliare un poco eh Domani sera
Vale Perfetto Mi amor voi al Curro eh
Buona giornata